you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the director
of the john smith center kezia dugdale
and conservative commentator
tim montgomery but let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
the telegraph looks at the duke of
cambridge's touching tribute to his late
grandfather prince philip with the
headline
he would want us to get on with the job
words apart the metro looks at prince
william and prince harry's very
different
and moving tributes to the duke of
edinburgh
we'll miss you grandpa that's the
headline in the mirror
the mail claims an exclusive with news
that senior roles have agreed that one
of them will always be
at the queen's side at future public
engagements
the financial times leads with boris
johnson ordering an investigation into
david cameron's private lobbying for
finance company
greensell capital cameron faces
inquiry the guardian also looked at the
pm's inquiry into his predecessor
while the star leads with people braving
the elements after lockdown with the
headline we're living
the dream dave
and kezia dugdale and tim montgomery
standing by to take us through the
newspapers welcome
to you both good evening we're going to
start with the
financial times and the story that we've
been uh running our lead story
uh the investigation into uh david
cameron and his links with uh green cell
being launched today tim you've had a
look at this
yes well i kind of have mixed views
about this uh jillian i think first of
all
um we have definitely a problem in this
country
of incredibly close links between
big business and big government and it's
understandable in many reasons because
when you have government spending about
half of national income
during crisis like we've just lived
through the decisions it takes on
funding and regulation have
amazingly big impact on business and
business obviously wants to ensure
that those impacts are managed so
there's definitely something to fix
and to be organized and whether david
cameron and focusing
uh the inquiry on him is fair because in
many ways
he's only doing what everyone already
does in the system that we have so
yes good we need a reform of the system
but i wonder if there's a little bit of
some brexiteers in government
settling scores with david cameron um on
the specific uh
issue of how he's lobbied cassie do you
think it's unfair to to focus
the investigation on an individual on
david cameron
no i would have to disagree a little bit
with what tim's just said you know he
describes david cameron as just doing
what everybody else does well
not everybody else has the chancellor's
phone number or the health secretary's
phone number
ready in their phone and that's the
worry people have is that a former prime
minister
might have extra power extra contacts at
their disposal that are used
in a way that the public should know
about in the interests of transparency
and in
decency really and that's why this is
such a big story it's become a bit of a
running soar
for david cameron and indeed the uk
government now for i think a good 40
days broken first by the financial times
the sunday times coming in quickly to
develop the story
got a situation now an unprecedented
situation where the prime minister
is conducting an inquiry into one of his
predecessors
actions i don't think we've had that
before it's a detail in the financial
time story
and we do need to get to the bottom of
what's happening here and we do need to
talk about
what prime ministers do when they retire
from public office
what's an appropriate way for them to
behave what are the appropriate types of
business
relationships that they should have in
the 21st century is that the bigger
issue tim that there aren't clear
guidelines as to what happens to
prime ministers once they leave office
how they conduct themselves you know
what are the lines that they shouldn't
be crossing it's not as distinct and
clear as perhaps it is the in the united
states
there are guidelines and actually it's
been well sort of reported that before
he became prime minister
david cameron himself said this all
needed to be cleaned up
and he for example introduced a two-year
rule whereby you couldn't lobby
um after you left office and for that
period of time to try and create a
a break between the power that you had
and
the influence you could possibly have
later now i think gordon brown
today has said that limit should be five
years and perhaps gordon brown
is right but i don't think we can avoid
that the fundamental issue though is
that
if you do have government so impactful
on business and during the um crisis
for example 10 years ago after the stock
market crash the amount of help
government was giving to businesses just
to survive particularly in the financial
sector
was enormous and aleister darling had to
then labor chancellor had to regularly
talk
to business to ensure business
has its say in things that impact them
you know often politicians are the best
connected they know how it works so
i think this is a lot more complicated
than just seeing it as an issue of
former politicians being greedy it's
about the nature of the kind of state we
have in the united kingdom
and we will await the findings of the
inquiry that's been launched um let's
have a look at the guardian kezia uh
lots of people out shopping on the the
high streets um
is this what we need to to boost the
economy
well we do need it but i'm afraid at the
moment it's only happening in england
and i think to lesser degree in
in wales the shops are very firmly shut
here in scotland
the hairdressers are open again though
and i know where i'm going on friday
morning
but yes we needed a little bit of an
economic emulator quite a significant
one actually to make up for what
ground we've lost over the past 12
months or so and you had an earlier
report today showing that the footfall
on our high streets is twice what it was
a week ago but it's still markedly down
on what it was a year ago
it shows you that there's still a long
long way to go until we get the economic
recovery that we desperately desperately
need
and what do you think the impact will be
um tim
of many people getting used to shopping
online during
the various lockdowns do you think that
they might be reluctant to to go back to
the high street
i think some people will but um i can't
remember julian exact percentage i don't
have it in front of me but i think we
saw
amazon's revenue or profits up by 50
percent over the last year you know 50
percent
and um i'm not a big fan of amazon but
partly the reason they how they treat
their warehouse workers
but i've been using amazon it's just so
convenient it's only been the way you
better get hold of good so
the high street was already in trouble
um even before this crisis
and i think it's going to be hard for it
to fully recover now
because of this blow that it's um it
suffered people are
now used to um getting parcels delivered
and finding ways of receiving those
parcels even when they're not at home
yeah indeed let's move to the mirror
um and their front page we'll miss you
grandpa um and this the tributes from
the two princes kezia
yes it's a lovely photo isn't it and two
very
respectful but very different
contributions from the two princes
talking about their
grandfather's life we know that um
prince harry is now returned to the
united kingdom from america he's going
into
a period of isolation or quarantine
ahead of the funeral on saturday he'll
have to be tested before he's able to go
to that so
and we have had those statements and
very heartfelt and very fond
uh both of them speak of their
grandfather and it's a nice read and
it's a beautiful picture
yes i mean there has been much made of
the the
tone of the statement and they've been
quite different
um but why wouldn't they be tim
yeah they're different people and i
think um harry's first statement i think
on saturday
was criticized for example by andrew
pierce who regularly appears on these
paper slots as lacking the sort of
warmth and humanity that he thought
should have been paid to a grand par
whereas
today of course harry's statement is
great you know the legend of the
barbecue legend of banter i forget
exactly what he said but it's a really
heartfelt personal tribute from
from harry and um i think we have to
remember that
whether we're talking about harry or
william or some other members of the
royal family
this isn't just the public engagement
thing that is
for most of us they've lost their
grandfather they've lost their father
they've lost someone who
i think the public has underestimated
how central he was to the
to the royal family and i think we're
gonna
see probably quite a lot of judgment
about how all of these royal characters
are behaving
and this week but it's a grieving family
and i think we should give them a bit of
slack
and yeah hope on the margins that harry
and william perhaps have some time
together a little bit of
time for very much needed reconciliation
but it is a funeral uh for a family for
a grandfather
at the end of this week and um that is
really what time we should i think
reflect on
yes yeah that is the the central issue
they are a family
grieving we we are all part of that
grief and
uh many people are passing comment but
we still have to respect that they are
a private family well of course
and i can't say i'm looking forward to
the weekend's newspaper coverage where i
think we'll
see pages and pages of and people
pouring over the details of body
language and who is looking at who and
who said what to who and all the rest of
it in quite an
unedifying way this is going to be a
small you know because of
er good without question but it will be
broadcast to the nation
and it will be the central focus of what
we talk about for
many many days to come and you're right
at the end of the day
these are two still relatively young men
who've lost their grandfather and i
think everybody across the country
regardless of their political views or
what they think of the monarchy can
relate to that it's about loss and
grief and everybody knows what that
feels like
and they're actually also talking about
the the uh difference in the the two
statements from the princes um harry
saying a legend
of banter and um william saying a
lifetime
of service but but both statements
showing the clear love and
respect and sense of loss that both of
them are feeling tim
absolutely and um i think i think it's
the
mail front page um
we may get to at 11 30 and talks about
the commitment of all the
royal family to sort of now ensure that
the queen isn't alone
and um public engagements and i think
that's what
hopefully will unite um the royal family
at the moment there are obviously some
differences not just the difference in
the statements that have been issued but
you know all to do with the harry megan
affair we've all been
living through overlay but i think there
is in the royal families there is in the
country
huge respect for the queen and a huge
awareness
that she does have this void in her life
that she's uh
admitted and all of her family
children and grandchildren help hoping
to
step forward to fill that void in the
best way they can
that's that that's the thing i think
that they can best best do
and this uh the politicians paying
respects
uh to shirley williams who's died at the
age of 90.
yes as you see i'm really sad sorry
tonight 90 years old
shirley williams a huge political figure
for so many
i think she had 50 years of service
across
the two houses the house of commons and
the house of lords first of all
for the labour party she was a minister
in
jim callahan's government covering both
the education brief and the science
brief and
described here as a trailblazer in the
guardian because she was
a very lonesome female face for a long
time in politics
she later split from the labour party to
join the
sdp in the early 80s as part of the gang
of four and then became president of the
liberal democrats and ended up leading
the liberal democrats in the house of
lords
and later in her life it's a real
stalwart of centrist politics
it much loved by my many across the
political spectrum i saw it earlier
tonight
a lovely picture on twitter from joel
swinton the former leader of the liberal
democrats
a picture of shirley williams holding
joe swinton's son so
you know she'll be a big loss to many
people across liberal democrats and
beyond
yes and tim many saying that that she
should have been the first
female prime minister i mean she was was
that good
well i'm a conservative so i was happy
that margaret
the prime minister but you know on the
subject of her sort of standing up for
feminism and one of your colleagues and
julian
and sophie ridge visited an anecdote
that shelley williams shared with her
and
in the early days of mps being in
parliament when i think they were just
she was one of them and in the tightly
packed division lobbies in the house of
commons
she thought about how she would get
pinched and her colleagues would get
pinched in the bottom
in the legs by men misbehaving and all
the women
agreed to get together for the next time
this happened and they all wore still
stiletto heels and they agreed that any
time that they were pinned
they would ensure that they were
stiletto these men and a
one mp arrived in the commons tea room
the next day
limping and all the women gather around
him and say oh what's the matter you
look very hurt and
he said it was gout but um i think uh
shirley williams and her colleagues have
made a uh
a big statement on equality that night
yes inflicted gout uh
yes quite uh just time for this um
cartoon matt cartoon in the
telegraph kezia talk us through it
yeah so this is a cute take on the
greens hill story that we covered
earlier from the financial times about
the degree to which david cameron can
get you what you want in government so
the
the joke here being you know if you
can't get your hairdresser on the end of
the phone give david cameron
a call and he'll sort it out for you
instead so very tongue-in-cheek from
matt here
yes yeah heavily tongue-in-cheek um
tim did you manage to get to uh have a
pint outside today
no but sort of a slightly christmasy
feeling for me tonight because
i'm talking to you from salisbury but
tomorrow i'm having lunch with four
friends outside i think it'll all be uh
very uh socially distanced et cetera but
just the idea of
going up meeting friends doing things
that we used to take for
for granted has got me very excited so
kathy and tim we shall see you in the
next hour thank you very much